I hope you're ready it'll be here any  minute is that a rifle you don't know  what a rifle looks like it's just sort  were your thing and guns were mine but I  guess we were both doing guns now I just  didn't know that I see it within you  fear jealousy betrayal  is it all beauty to cleanse the universe  of this weakness you know they told me  you people were conceited douchebags  but that isn't true at all dude I'm  using my wrong I put the seat belt on  so it's saving the galaxy again we're  really gonna be able to jack up our  price if with two-time galaxy Davis  [Music]  hi  sometimes the thing you're searching for  your whole life strength you're by your  side all along you're right no family  so maybe her  after all these years I've found you and  who the hell are you I'm your dad  you